the gyro can experience had someone
should do a psychological profile of
those people particularly the tobacco
people because it's like such a direct
correlation between tobacco and cancer
like it's the climate change thing it's
almost like boy it's so hard to track
because it's so far in advance and if
you say the climate change isn't real
what deaths are caused is it directly
attributable to that like how do you you
know I'm saying but like cancer and
cigarettes it's like here's a person
they smoke cigarettes they have cancer
you said it didn't come from cigarettes
what does that feel like to be that
person that actively tries to the well
they're essentially lying there lying
for money
they're lying let me just back up one
second and then talk about that just
because I want to make it clear that
while the the link between smoking and
cancer may seem entirely obvious there's
enough of a delay that opens up the
opportunity for denial the link between
putting greenhouse gases in the air and
dramatic climate change that's actually
as established well-established as the
links between smoking and cancer it's
just that there it is a more complicated
process and and there's potentially more
of a delay and it depends in large part
on what humans do along the way so so it
does it does get kind of complicated as
far as psychologically profiling the the
tobacco companies I mean or the tobacco
executives I won't presume to suggest
this book does that but but I do write a
lot about what the these folks were
saying not just to the public but to you
know internally we've got some internal
documents and and certain things that
may have been public utterances but were
clearly just sort of part of their
internal rationalization and for example
I start the book with a quote from the
head of Philip Morris who says who knows
what you would do if you didn't smoke
maybe you'd beat your wife maybe you
drive cars fast and you know that that's
part of how I think the tobacco industry
approach to this they would they would
imagine this sort of counterfactual
where you know a world without tobacco
without cigarettes and then they would
imagine what that would be like and of
course they'd always imagined it was
much much much worse mother Angela
right yeah I read that part and also
that the man in question
wound up quitting cigarettes right yeah
he had it right exactly yeah that was
the question and we never really did
find that out it's such a strange way to
live your life to to be deceptive in a
way that you know is gonna I mean that
there's I don't know how many people
have gotten cancer from cigarettes but
it's probably Millions well and it isn't
just cancer it's heart disease etc so
millions I mean I've seen an estimate
that in the 20th century smoking killed
I want to make sure I get this right I
think it was a hundred million people
more than more than maybe both Wars
world wars but together it's 7 million a
year I think is the is the global death
toll in the u.s. it's four hundred and
eighty thousand a year yeah
directly to tribute of all right they
trace they trace it to to directly
attributable now you know it these are
extreme examples tobacco is the most
famous and extreme example and I talked
about a lot of other examples but I
think it's actually you know a fairly
common thing for people to go pretty far
down the road of denial when they are
working in an industry and and this is
sort of the process I tried to explore a
little bit in the book they're working
in an industry they're confronted with
some accusation that they have caused
harm they check their gut and their gut
says no we didn't intend to cause harm
we don't feel guilty and so their mind
starts to come up with the reasons why
it must be wrong and their tribal
instincts which are never more than just
a millimeter below the surface for
pretty much any of us but but certainly
in this case get triggered so they
immediately think well these people
accusing me must have an ulterior motive
they must be they want money they want
power they want attention they've got
some sinister political objective and
then the the other part of that tribal
dynamic is they start thinking about
themselves and and they're truly lofty
mission which isn't just to sell a
product but something else
[Applause]